for today so before we get started I
want to share kind of my motivation for
doing this session and that is because
this is a very common question that I
get from Udacity students as well as
some of my own personal clients but it's
a common question that you'll see and
you may have personally experienced and
it may either why you're joining in
today but one of the things that I've
realized throughout my coaching career
and through my own career is that you're
not always going to be provided with
opportunities to further your career
sometimes those will be available to you
and sometimes you just have to create
those for yourself and this topic really
inspired me because it was a big change
in my own personal career where I felt
like I was in more control and I felt
more empowered and more independent to
actually help myself progress to the
next level so this is definitely a skill
that you all will probably use now as
you're completing your nano degree or if
you're already finished it but also
throughout the rest of your career and
keeping these things in mind as you
progress and know that this is not
something that you do once and never do
again it's something that you continue
to do in a skill that you continue to
build so just a brief introduction of
myself so I'm a career coach here with
Udacity I've been here with me since
mid-april so a little over six months my
background is in higher education and I
have more previously worked with a lot
of different college and university
students but upon starting my own
coaching business I've worked with a lot
of different clients ranging different
age groups as well as different
industries
I personally specialized in LinkedIn
that's one of the areas that I focus a
lot of my energy and efforts towards so
if you're ever interested in LinkedIn
specifically feel free to reach out for
a coaching session but this is really my
favorite thing that I like to do as a
career coach is getting to present to
groups whether it's via webinars or for
in-person and really engaging with
groups so that we can kind of spread the
knowledge and make sure that you all are
prepared
entering your careers as well as
furthering your careers so a brief
overview of today's agenda so I already
kind of introduced myself in a topic but
we're gonna talk of arey briefly about
why is it so important to have
experience why are employers so why are
they stressing it so much for us
to have this experience for being able
to succeed well in the workplace and how
we can prove to them that we are capable
of performing in those roles we'll talk
about how do we know what specific
experiences we should be gaining so if
an employer says you know we're looking
for somebody with a little bit more
experience these are some strategies
that you can use to figure out what
those experiences are we'll talk about
ideas and strategies for actually
gaining that experience we'll continue
talking about strategies for creating
your own experiences so not necessarily
relying on anybody else to help you get
these experiences that you need to be
marketable to employers and then we'll
talk about a few other strategies we'll
open it up for some Q&A so if you have
any questions that you've been wanting
to ask the coach where if there are any
questions that stem from this
presentation we will open that up for
you to ask those questions and then we
will close out so we're gonna go ahead
and jump right in so the first question
and in kind of a really important thing
to know is why is it important to have
relevant experience when you're applying
for a job or when you're in the process
of getting a job and so I put a note
here because I think this is an issue
that a lot of students and job seekers
have is they kind of approach the job
search from their own perspective and
not from the perspective of somebody who
is actually hiring someone or someone
who is a hiring manager so as you go
through this process I want you to
continue to kind of remove yourself from
your current situation and put yourself
in the mindset of somebody who's hiring
for a job somebody who is going to be
there several hours a week and really
committing to that business or that
company or organization so I'm here a
couple of reasons why it's important it
gives you a chance to apply some of the
skills that you're learning in
real-world situations so very similar to
you know your nano degree or a college
degree you're getting to work on
projects that are inspired by real world
situations and you're learning these
skills that are going to be extremely
relevant for the real world but you're
not actually using these to solve
problems for a business a lot of times
sometimes you will get the chance to do
that but employers are gonna see how
you've actually done this in a
real-world setting so that they have a
good understanding of how you might be
able to do the same for them what it
also does is it showcases your ability
to solve problems and accomplish goals
so if you've been to any of my webinars
or had a coaching call with me this is
something that I stress a lot is that
every single job opening really that's
ever existed is either there to solve a
problem or accomplish a goal and so if
you're not able to showcase your ability
to do that then you're missing a huge
opportunity to showcase
being a quality candidate for that role
it also gives you a chance to showcase
your ability to work on teams or with
supervisors or direct reports and so if
you're doing nanodegree projects or
sometimes if you're working on a regular
college degree you're you're doing a lot
of this work independently and so it can
be helpful to gain some real relevant
experience working on teams or working
with the supervisor or working with
people that you supervise as a way to
develop that skill set because it's not
necessarily something that you can just
learn in a class and know how to do it
it's something that you have to learn
and then practice and continue
practicing another thing to mention is
online courses often miss soft skills
training so that's something that you'll
hear a lot from hiring managers
especially with younger professionals
that they lack the soft skills they lack
communication skills they lack teamwork
they lack critical thinking and
problem-solving and so that's what real
world experience a little out of you to
gain and in that sometimes online
courses don't always allow you to do and
then lastly this is kind of more
personal but it really helps narrow and
solidify your career goals and so if you
have an entry
in one area let's say for example you're
interested in digital marketing and then
you start to getting some experience and
you realize maybe this isn't so much for
me maybe I like the strategy side more
maybe I want to work in a different area
you don't really get to gain that all
the time just from learning sometimes
you have to get in on the ground and
actually start learning from those
experiences to really figure out what
you like as well as what you're good at
and then the opposite so those types of
things are very appealing to employers
because it goes through a lot of
different things that you might not
necessarily gain just from a degree or
online learning platform so I want you
all to jump in and chime in in the chat
so I want to know from you all what are
the types of jobs that you're trying to
land now or after completing your nano
degree so what are the types of jobs
that you're targeting if this is
something that you don't know I highly
suggest that you schedule a coaching
call with one of us or take some time to
reflect because this can oftentimes be
the first step and really creating the
uneffective job search strategy but I
want to know what jobs you're targeting
so an AI engineer front an engineer
machine learning engineer so the
engineers are winning right now anybody
else data engine here machine learning
engineer front in full stack digital
marketing data analysts business
analysts machine learning in okay great
so we have a really good mix front-end
engineer a lot of people going after
similar things but it's good to know
that if you don't have a focus I would
suggest that you do some really some
critical thinking maybe reach out to a
coach to kind of process that with you
but this can be one of the most
important parts of actually you know
going through your job search strategy
because if you're lacking experience and
you also don't know where you want to go
it can be very difficult for you to
create the appropriate steps to gaining
those experience as well as landing jobs
in those roles so it's great that you
have
solid idea of the types of jewels jobs
that you are targeting so great we have
a good mix of different job goals and so
hopefully I can utilize that as we
continue to go through the rest of the
presentation so addressing the next
point how do I know what experiences
that I should be gaining so one of the
best resources is the Job Description
and I think that people oftentimes
underestimate how important a job is in
it I think oftentimes people will go job
searching and they're looking for
opportunities and they'll just apply
based on the title and then the
qualifications at the bottom they don't
actually read through the job
description critically to have an
understanding of what are the specific
skills or experiences that they need to
have and so oftentimes job descriptions
are broken down very similarly there's
kind of a similar template that most
companies use that first paragraph will
usually be kind of an overview of the
company that second kind of paragraph or
the second major area usually covers the
overarching goal of that position so it
may include some high-level roles and
responsibilities that that person is
kind of in in charge of doing as it
relates to the goals of the business and
then after that you usually have some
bullet pointed lists that kind of
highlight more day to day or other types
of functions and so I would encourage
you to really go through those
critically and look and see what are the
experiences that employers are looking
for so if you are targeting a
machine-learning engineer position go
through and find five or six different
job descriptions these don't necessarily
have to be jobs that you plan on
applying for but review all of those and
see what are the things that they have
in common do I have all of these
experiences any skills that they're
looking for if not there's a gap there
and you should start making a list of
those so if you notice that on four
different job descriptions it says that
you need to have the ability to analyze
data and present it in a way that's
visually appealing or something like
that and if you don't have that
experience then maybe you can write that
down and say okay one of the experiences
that I need to
gain is data visualization so if I have
experience learning that in an online
course that's helpful but if I've never
actually put it to use then that's
something that I need to kind of make a
list of and work to gain experience
doing that specifically so job
descriptions are a really great resource
for that and I would just encourage you
even outside of this presentation and as
you're applying for jobs and looking for
jobs that needs to be reviewed extremely
critically for every single aspect and
every single stage of your job search so
knowing those job descriptions is very
important it's also helpful if you are
trying to plan out your next steps these
are experiences that you can be gaining
as you get there so let's say for
example you aren't ready to job search
right now but you know you might within
the next two or three years it's better
that you start reviewing some of these
job descriptions now so you can make a
plan about I'm gonna gain this
experience I'm gonna look to gain this
experience and I'm gonna do that so that
when it is time for my job search I'm
ready and I don't have to say that I
don't have these experiences or you
don't have to try to get them all at
that time you're being proactive about
your approach so next is informational
interviews so this is basically a chance
for you to chat with somebody who may be
in a role that you're looking to get
into so let's say you want to be a
business analyst an informational
interview may just be a conversation
that you're having with a business
analyst that you know or reaching out to
somebody on LinkedIn or maybe it's
somebody who actually works in that role
for the company that you're interested
in working for so informational
interviews are basically just kind of a
chance for you to sit down and have a
conversation with someone to learn a
little bit more that's why it's called
an informational interview
you're basically there to gain
information and learn how you can better
improve your chances for potentially
applying for a role like that so those
are a couple different areas to consider
as well somebody who's doing the role
already that you may know or you know
may have easy access to maybe in the
same networking or professional group as
you or it could be somebody who actually
worked for that company and you can
actually ask them the question what are
the experiences that you all are looking
or what things can I do to stand out as
a qualified candidate and then lastly I
would just include LinkedIn research and
so if you want to be an AI engineer type
that in the search box and find people
who are actually doing that right now or
if you're you want to be an Android
developer type that in and find people
who are doing that right now and then
you can look at their description of
their job and see some of the different
things that they're doing so you can use
that as a way to determine whether there
are experiences that you need to gain
and and that gives you an idea of
somebody who's actually doing it it's
not just some generic job description
it's actually somebody who's doing it on
a day-to-day basis these are all really
good ways for you to kind of fill that
gap and so you're not wondering well
what experiences should I be gaining
what skills should I be developing these
are all different tools that will give
you that information
so let's take a look at this job posting
that was actually on Udacity so I pulled
this because I wanted to show you kind
of what you should be doing as you are
going through in reviewing job
descriptions so if you're looking
through there's gonna be a lot of
different bullets highlighting all of
the different things that you're going
to be doing with that role so what
you're gonna want to do is look for
those major roles responsibilities what
are the things that really stand out as
being very important to that role one of
the things that I like to do personally
is print it out for me I'm a very kind
of hands-on visual person I don't do
everything on the computer so it helps
me to print it out and then one of the
things that I will do is I'll have like
a yellow highlighter and I'll highlight
everything that I have in yellow so
these are the skills that I have these
are experiences that I can talk about
this is what I'm confident in use
another color maybe a green or an orange
and highlight the areas where you might
be missing so you're starting to
indicate what are where my gaps where my
gaps an experience where my guests and
skillset where my gaps and software
knowledge so that you have a visual
breakdown of the things that you should
be doing I mean going back to what I
mentioned before do
this with a couple of different job
descriptions so that you can kind of
find some things in common so that
you're not spending hours upon hours
preparing for one job description where
that's the only one that asks you to
have experience with a certain software
program you want to focus on kind of
those major areas because some of those
very unique or specified qualifications
or things that they're willing to train
you on but those major experiences are
things that you're gonna want to get and
so as you look at the experiences and
skills that you do have so maybe the
ones that you highlighted and yellow you
can start to prepare some of your most
impressive stories so that if you do
have time for an interview you can talk
about your ability to perform well in
those roles and how you've already done
it in the past not just saying that you
can do it
showing showcasing that through stories
of past successes and then like I said
make a list of the things that you don't
have and use that as a guide I made it
no at the bottom
do not let job descriptions discourage
you I don't know that job seekers are
oftentimes educated at how some
companies create job descriptions
whereas a lot of these HR departments
and a lot of the people who are treating
these job descriptions are basically
showcasing their ideal candidate this is
kind of the perfect person that they
hope would apply for this job and so if
you're kind of behind on one area or
another or asks for five years but you
only have three don't let these things
discourage you and I'll say that just
from my own perspective I've gotten
probably two or three different jobs in
my past that I wasn't technically
qualified on paper and it was because I
was able to showcase the experience that
I did have I was able to tell great
stories and I was able to convince them
that they were not taking a risk by me
being able to learn those other skills
that I was missing and so don't let
those things discourage you from
applying if you feel like you can do the
job well but you have to have a lot of
self awareness for that you can't just
say oh yeah I've been doing this for one
year but I could be a director because
I'm
leader you know be realistic and be
self-aware of your skills and your
experiences to know whether or not it's
a job that you would actually stand a
chance for especially because every
single job that you're applying for is
also a competition with other qualified
individuals it's not just a matter of
whether or not you can do it it's still
a competition so keep all of those
things in mind as you're reviewing those
job descriptions so now probably what
most of you came for what are some ideas
and strategies for me to actually gain
some of these experiences that employers
are saying that I need so first things
first volunteer so I have gotten to a
point in my own career where it doesn't
matter what level I'm at I will always
find a way to volunteer because I'm
always looking to continuing grow and as
times change there will become needs for
multiple different kinds of experiences
so a couple of great opportunities are
our professional organizations so if
their organizations in your area they
could be focused specifically on kind of
your content area or your area of
expertise or they could be kind of
community organizations so for me like I
said I'm based in Atlanta I'm involved
in the Urban League of Greater Atlanta
young professionals I'm also involved in
the Hispanic and young professionals and
entrepreneurs organization out here and
so like I said even though I feel like
I'm at a good place in my career I don't
want to take a step back and not
continuously be working on what my goals
are and what my next steps are so
professional organizations whether
they're community-based or based on your
area of expertise are great
opportunities for you to not only gain
experience but network and so one of the
things that I would encourage you to do
is look for those organizations that
allow you to practice the things that
you're you're learning so for example
the one of the organizations that I have
involved in there is an innovation and
Technology Committee the organization is
not focused on technology at all but
there's a committee that showcases that
there's a need for having IT
professionals help build this
organization so that would be a great
way for you to getting some
experience another thing that I think
people oftentimes forget about is there
a lot of entrepreneurs and small
business owners who need a lot of help
on the tech side they may be extremely
skilled in their content area but they
don't have a strong background in tech
and I promise you being an entrepreneur
myself people are not going to be that
hesitant to hire people who are willing
to work for free
especially if you're able to showcase a
passion for the work that they're doing
as well as some skill set that you have
completed so think about you know people
who you may know who are running
businesses who may need help working on
the back end of their website or may
need help
automating some of their systems or
different areas where you feel like you
could step in and really assist them so
that basically kind of covers small
businesses as well maybe there's a
restaurant down the street from your
house where you love their food but you
know that there could be some
improvements to their website or to
their email marketing or to anything
like that
reach out be able to work for free or
work for you know less amount of money
so that you can gain that experience
especially with the skill sets that you
all are gaining I know we know that you
deserve to be paid for that work but
often times these companies and these
entrepreneurs don't have the money to
pay for you but they have access to
extremely beneficial networks as well as
potential opportunities to connect you
with people who are who might be in that
industry and it's also a great way to
build your resume so don't ever count
out volunteering even though we all know
that you deserve to be paid for your
work and then lastly create your own
jobs or your own internships and so if
you are able to find a company that you
want to work for it's probably gonna be
more likely for smaller companies to
help you do this versus major companies
but you can actually go in and create
your own kind of job description and
present that as a proposal one of the
things that I did when I was in grad
school was I found a department that
never had any interns and I drafted an
entire job description and scheduled a
meeting with the department head
and presented that as a way to do a free
internship for the semester and they
actually accepted it and I was able to
even get college credit for it so don't
underestimate the power of creating your
own experiences and a lot of times if
you're willing to invest and put in the
time and effort upfront it'll make that
decision a lot easier for the person
who's making decisions because for the
most part people are lazy if we're being
honest people can be very lazy
especially as it relates to their jobs
and their job searches so oftentimes the
person who does the most work for was
willing to showcase their work ethic
upfront are the ones who end up winning
another opportunity is freelancing thing
this this seems to scare people and I'm
not sure entirely why but freelancing is
a great way to develop skills as well as
kind of generate some income for
yourself especially if you're not
currently working you can check out some
of these platforms that I've listed on
the Fiverr
upwork or LinkedIn profile LinkedIn
profile was a game changer for me back
in 2017 when I first started my business
I was just writing resumes I wasn't even
doing career coaching I had completed
the certification and that was a great
tool for me to start finding clients who
were looking for resume writers so if
you're interested in kind of gaining
some income as well as some experience
while you're going through this process
give it a try if there's nothing that it
can hurt from you at least making an
effort to do this because there's no way
I would ever have this job with Udacity
if it wasn't for me starting that
business in 2017 I've never worked
professionally as a career coach before
this role it was because I took on that
certification and ran my own business
and showcased my ability to help clients
succeed through my business that made my
candidacy appealing to Udacity so don't
underestimate the power of freelancing
you don't have to run a million dollar
business to be successful freelancer you
could make an extra 50 bucks a month and
gain great experience and that still
could be worth it for you but obviously
that's gonna depend on your situation
financially as much time that you have
and how much you're willing to commit
towards it so like I mentioned you can
make money and build your portfolio
while you continue to search and then
lastly I put this under freelance
because I think it can is start a blog
you know this is a great opportunity for
you to network and I don't think that
people realize the benefits of being
able to do that you can interview people
for your blog as a great way to start
off a connection with somebody let's say
you know there there's somebody on
LinkedIn in your area who works for a
company that you're interested in you
know reach out to them and say hey I'm
interested in interviewing you for my
blog and understanding what it's like as
on a day to day basis for a Android
developer or an iOS developer or
something like that it's also a great
way for you to stay up to date on
industry trends so that as you're out
connecting with people you have an
understanding of what are the hot topics
that people are talking about it
showcases that you're well versed in
your industry as well as that you keep
up to date on industry trends which we
all know is extremely important but I
think even more so important tech
because of how quickly it moves but as I
mentioned as well with the blog is that
you can also kind of reach out to people
for interviews or feature them a lot of
times people are not gonna hesitate from
free publicity so that can be a great
opportunity for you as well and that's
something that you could very easily
list on your resume that you're kind of
going through in between a cap period
and you can also include links to that
as well so don't hesitate to freelance
I will say that if you are looking for
assistance with this are a lot of our
career coaches do have their own
businesses but I wouldn't say that we
are small business coaches not all of us
so don't expect us to be able to give
you the ins and outs of building a
business and business planning strategy
but if you just kind of what some
insights on what it's like for some of
us then that could be an option as well
because a lot of us do kind of do some
of this work as well and like I said I
wouldn't have this job right now if it
wasn't for freelancing so don't count it
out and don't be afraid to do it there's
nothing to fear as it relates to that
um looks like okay so another thing to
consider is take on some additional
projects with your current employer so
if you're working in a role that is not
so much related to what you want to do
but you know that your company has that
that department or people that are doing
that kind of work asked to to join some
of those committees or be involved with
some of that work or take on more tech
roles within your current job the things
that are just kind of related to what
you're wanting to do and that can be
really helpful for you as you think
about transitioning especially if you
want to transition within your current
company I have talked to several Udacity
students who want to stay with their
current company but want to do something
close more closely related to what
they're doing they're nanodegree in and
some of them have been able to do that
so don't underestimate the power of
gaining these experiences while you're
still with your company another thing to
consider is you know maybe you don't
need but you kind of want to use this
experience to get that so I would really
encourage that you look into these
opportunities if you have a good a good
relationship with your supervisor or
other leaders in the company reach out
to them and ask them if they're
opportunities that they think might be
beneficial for you if it means you
transitioning to a different role or a
different company but obviously you have
to know your relationship with your
supervisor you can't just tell them you
can't tell every single supervisor hey
I'm ready to leave can you help me do
that some will be more supportive than
that than others so you have to kind of
know that relationship
another thing is shadow other employees
so maybe you take a half-day to kind of
just go through what it is like on a
day-to-day basis with somebody who's in
that role that can give you an
opportunity to not only gain some
experience but see what it's really like
kind of on the in the grassroots what
it's like to really be working in that
area another way is more additional
informational interviews so maybe
interviewing people at your
current company who are doing those
things ask them to meet you out for
lunch or maybe to grab coffee in between
meetings or something like that so that
you can build more relationships with
people who are in your current company
and then the last bullet like I
mentioned before it can be much easier
to transition within your current
company then it can be if you're
changing careers in general so if you
work at XYZ company and you want to work
in a different company and you're trying
to change careers that's a lot more
difficult than it is to change careers
within your own company because you've
already kind of built that credibility
you've already showcased your work ethic
you've already invested in the company
and their values and so it can be a much
easier transition to do that than to try
to jump to a completely different
company and that can also be a great
bridge to kind of address a gap between
that career change so maybe your dream
job is to work at Apple as an iOS
developer maybe that's too big of a jump
for you right now so maybe you
transition to being an iOS developer in
your current company now to Apple you're
a lot more appealing as a candidate than
you would be trying to make that direct
transition for some of those more
competitive jobs so keep those things in
mind as well don't underestimate the
things that are already made available
to you within your current role okay so
that was a lot a lot of different
strategies and tips so I want to know if
there's anything that you gained today
or anything that you've been reflectable
reflecting on recently and I want to
know what are some things that you will
do or maybe one thing that you would do
to start gaining some experience I want
like a very specific thing so maybe you
can say I'm going to reach out to my
cousin who builds websites and I'm going
to ask if I can help with the backend so
I want you to go ahead and type in the
chat what are some things that you will
do or just one thing that you will do
maybe this week maybe next week maybe
next one but not putting it off
- too late what is something that you
will do to start gaining some of these
experiences that you know you'll need
I'm thinking about writing a blow
and start taking interviews great start
a blog probably one of the easiest
things that you can can can do to kind
of start gaining experience I will say
that that's gonna be more so helpful for
kind of networking and staying up to
date there are still a lot of companies
that are gonna want to see some direct
experience so that alone may not be
enough but it's definitely a great start
what else
reach out to university to find
volunteering jobs that's great I'm
already working for a friends website
that's awesome I'm going to freelance
for subject matter experts I know I need
help with that so don't ever
underestimate that freelancing great
ideas look to contribute to github
projects that's great one of the things
in keep them in as I'm talking keep
going tell me what your you're gonna do
you need to learn how to showcase these
as well so if you are taking the time to
look into some of these opportunities to
gain experience you need to find a good
way to sell that on your resume to sell
that on your Linkedin and to sell that
in conversations to employers because
you are effectively selling yourself
every time it comes to a job search and
so you need to be able to showcase that
in a way that is relevant impressive and
kind of powerful to those employers
applying for intern good good good the
front end developer running an ad word
campaign for my friends configuring
Google Analytics for her I wish one of
my friends would do that for me so
that's that's great oh that's a great
way for you to start utilizing some of
those digital marketing skills that
you're learning in your nano degree
program with that what else let's get a
couple more I'm working for my own
website that's great especially for
somebody in digital marketing you need
to make sure that your personal
marketing is on point I had a
conversation with a digital marketing
student a couple of days ago and I told
them if you don't have a good resume I
probably wouldn't trust your ability to
market my own products if you can't
market yourself so that's a good thing
to keep in mind I've signed up for
Python class and Udacity because I've
seen Python as a skill that many job
scriptures required great I also want to
contribute to open source projects great
so these are all really really good
I've been working as a freelance Android
developer on up work but an interviewer
said freelancing doesn't count as
experience don't listen to that that is
one person's opinion obviously I think
that I am an example that it does count
as experience I've been able to learn
all of the different skills that I have
as a career coach over the last several
years just by doing it on my own
pursuing certifications and and doing
those things so don't let one person's
opinion let you decide how you're going
to continue throughout your job search
so that's a couple of things to keep in
mind as well as you're talking to people
don't let people dictate the way that
you conduct your own job search because
everybody's got an opinion and that's
what makes job searching difficult
there's no right way or no one way to do
it and so you know I have different
opinions from somebody else who might be
a career coach from somebody else who
might be a recruiter so think critically
and figure out what works for you um but
don't let that I wouldn't I wouldn't pay
attention to that freelancing absolutely
counts as experience could you send the
recording so we record all of the
webinars so it's been recording as we're
going we won't send out the presentation
but the recording will be uploaded via
YouTube hopefully within the next couple
of days so if you has have missed a
couple of things you can go back and
re-watch this entire recording so I'll
make sure that that's sent out it won't
be sent to you directly via email we'll
probably post it in student hub and then
also just check out Udacity YouTube page
so go to YouTube find Udacity go to the
videos you you'll be able to find this
one once it's uploaded as well as all of
the other webinars that me and the other
career coaches have hosted in the past
great okay
so let's move on we only have a couple
more slides and I want to open it up for
for questions so just a couple of other
things to consider in I see Angela
kindly sent the link here in the chat so
if you want to maybe click on that and
then bookmark that you can see the ones
that we have
the ones that we will continue to record
so a couple of other things to consider
not gonna go too much in depth with
these because this is the topic of the
webinar but networking and personal
branding are huge as it relates to this
and so networking that you know that
means you know in person online getting
face to face time with people so that
people know who you are and what you're
looking to do so check out meetups look
on Eventbrite for events that are going
on in your area
you know utilize LinkedIn as a way to
connect with other people that can be
extremely helpful and then also personal
branding people really underestimate the
power of this and what I mean by this is
being recognized for what you're doing
so finding ways to showcase yourself as
a subject matter expert so for those of
you who talked about you know working
with SMEs or working with entrepreneurs
or subject matter experts to build their
business also pay attention to how their
branding themselves so one of the things
that I would share is is is Lincoln is a
great place to get started with that I'm
also finding maybe some tech blogs or
getting featured in articles just to
showcase your knowledge in this doing
public speaking like this webinars it's
not much to learn to learn how to host a
webinar on a topic of your expertise
host it for free so people have
knowledge of who you are and what you're
doing
so one thing that I like to share as it
relates to personal branding is because
of the work that I've been able to do
personally on my own brand and push that
through LinkedIn that's another reason
why I got this job with Udacity is they
actually reached out to me because they
saw the work that I was doing in the
content that I was putting out as well
as my past full-time role I got through
LinkedIn from them finding me so my last
two jobs my last two official jobs I've
never even applied for so keeping those
things in mind as well as it relates to
gaining experience sometimes that
experience can be your ability to
showcase your knowledge and your subject
matter expertise so this is kind of a
great area where that blogging would
fall into but don't ever underestimate
these two things especially together
they can be extremely
powerful and make it that much easier
for you to get a job if you do maybe
lakhs on the experience if people know
who you are and what you're good at they
may not need to see the the hands-on
experience that you have because you've
already showcased your ability to do
that work through social media through
getting featured in articles doing
public speaking appearances different
things like that so don't underestimate
the two of these as it relates to that
if you need help with those any further
feel free to schedule a coaching car
with myself or one of the other coaches
these are definitely areas that we can
help you with okay so I want to know
from this presentation because we are
wrapping up what is maybe your biggest
takeaway what is the thing that you've
learned and if you do still have
questions feel free to unmute yourself
or type it in the chat I want to know
what's your biggest takeaway or if there
was a question that I didn't address or
something anybody have any takeaways or
questions okay I see a question in the
chat how to handle failure after a
rejection at an interview so one thing
that people don't realize is that career
coaches like myself and some of our
other coaches we still have career goals
as well and that we still get rejections
from applying for jobs even when we
sometimes feel like we're doing
everything right we still sometimes
don't get that so I think one thing to
keep in mind is you know it's always
helpful to reach out to a coach or
somebody for a second opinion but just
because you don't get a job does not
mean that you're not qualified it does
not mean that you even need to work even
harder sometimes it can just mean that
you weren't the right fit for them and
that's another thing to keep in mind
just to kind of help you with that you
know internally and mentally is knowing
that if I don't get a job it's not
because I was
good enough it's still a competition you
know most of you probably know who
LeBron James is he doesn't win every
single game he's really good a very well
known player but he doesn't win every
single time and so keep those things in
mind as well
another thing that I would consider is
reaching out and asking for feedback
chances are you probably won't get too
many people who actually provide you
feedback but sometimes you will another
thing to consider is asking if there are
other opportunities for you to be
involved so if some of you might be
familiar with General Assembly is a
company that I used to teach for and I
got that opportunity to teach with them
because I missed out on a job that I
actually applied for so I reached out
very humbly and asked if they had other
opportunities and if they were
interested in some of the workshops that
I did and that was a way for me to kind
of deal with that rejection but another
thing for me personally as I'm always
trying to figure out how I can get
better and so reflecting a lot after
that interview and seeing if there are
areas that you can improve on might help
you add to that list of experiences that
you should be gaining great question one
of the takeaways is push yourself to
really find a job before it gets you so
yes being proactive is extremely
important it really changes the game as
it relates to the job search because
when you need a job your mind says
affected by that your approach is
affected by that you sometimes come
across more desperate than if you don't
need a job and so it's helpful to start
implementing some of these things in
advance while you're happy in your job
so that you don't have to go through
that struggle or that really difficult
transition when it's time for you to
make that move networking and personal
branding is the takeaway okay well that
that's good to know as well maybe
that'll be the topic for one of our
future webinars on how to handle a long
gap of nine years though the relevant
experience years back how to prove worth
so that's really challenging especially
if you have a gap I would make sure that
that gap is addressed because if you
just kind of try to hide it or cover it
up chances are employers or recruiters
are gonna have questions about that and
they will get a vibe that you're trying
to hide that you have a gap so
I would say you know maybe fill that gap
in with what you were doing it doesn't
mean that you have to list it out as a
job but maybe you were taking care of a
sick family member you could maybe list
that on your resume so they have an
understanding of what you were doing
within that time but one thing that I
would really consider as it relates to
gaps is don't let it happen to you if
you have a choice so let's say for
example you know you need to quit your
job or you know you need to move back
home or you know maybe you're having
having a baby and you want to take care
of that find ways to continue building
your your experience so maybe during
that transition period you're blogging
or you're freelancing and in your spare
time as a way to not have a gap but
addressing that gap I would say kind of
address it upfront and if you are kind
of writing a cover letter I would this
is my personal opinion this is not
necessarily what everybody would
recommend that you do but I would I'm
very big on addressing everything up
front and being transparent so that
nobody's time is wasted so that you know
if they have an issue with it then we
don't have to go through three
interviews for you to realize that my
gap is a problem to you blogging and
freelancing is the takeaway okay how to
handle a gap we kind of address that a
little bit and then also I believe
Angela did yes yep Angela did a webinar
on addressing a gap so that webinar I
would encourage you check out and that's
that should be on that same link that
she posted earlier all of our videos
were there
analyzing job postings yes is extremely
important so you said tech changes
quickly is that why there seems to be a
trend of people getting jobs in only
thing a few years do people say jobs for
15 years or more so I think Tech has
something to do with it but I also think
that it just this is my personal opinion
but I think it also has to deal with
generational differences so for you know
older generations they were loyal to
their companies because their companies
were loyal to them and then you started
seeing a lot of you know maybe like my
my parents and people their age were
getting laid off from jobs so you
started to lose a little bit of that
trust and the companies that you work
for you no longer see people working for
a company
and working there until retirement
because there just aren't as many
benefits as there used to be to doing
that well also like I said my personal
opinion a lot of younger people a lot of
Millennials are having children as much
as older generations were so they're
very focused on their careers and
they're focused on career growth and so
if you're in a role for two to three
years and you've learned about as much
as you can learn there's a big emphasis
on you know young professionals and
Millennials on xx to advance in learning
new skills and so I think that's
oftentimes another reason why people
change their rears but like I said
that's just a personal opinion there are
probably a lot of different reasons why
that might happen
um auditioning and networking is my
takeaway that's definitely a great
takeaway how to gain experience as an
Android developer on freelancing
websites you don't get unless you can
showcase I think a behind so as it
relates to getting that you you
freelancing is difficult especially in
the beginning so I would encourage you
to work for friends or work for free and
then start to gain some of those
testimonials and so as I mentioned
before when I started I was doing resume
writing and so I would help friends I
would help family members I would do
workshops for free and my only ask and
return from that was for people to share
their experience working with me and so
I was able to showcase through my
LinkedIn profile as well it's like
Google reviews and different things like
that people rating me five stars and
saying Bret helped me you know revise my
resume that helped me get several more
interviews and so it may be helpful for
you to get started doing those things
first but it's definitely a lot harder
in the initial stages and so maybe you
have to do things at a lower rate than
you might do or do them for free but you
know if you are gonna do something for
free at least ask for something like a
testimonial in return for that and then
as you're working with people depending
on the type of freelancing work that
you're doing
always always always try to track the
the progress that you're making so if
you are an Android developer and you
something for for some one track how
many visits they're getting or how many
people are downloading those apps or you
know whatever metrics or insights makes
sense for your business if you can
combine testimonials with success
stories then it's hard for people to to
disagree with you especially if you're
offering it at an affordable rate so
trust me and I know for a fact that it
can be difficult especially in those
early stages so I would encourage you if
if you're looking into some of those
other freelance platforms and those
aren't working maybe take a look at
LinkedIn profile endure as I said that
one was really helpful for me especially
when I was getting started let's see can
you cover personal branding and blogging
in the future absolutely um now I don't
have to think of my next topic so thank
you for that I'll probably talk a little
bit about personal branding getting
featured in articles and stuff now that
I know that students will will show up
for that I will definitely do that how
to talk about Udacity nano degree in my
resume so this is a great question I get
this question a lot from students so
there are a couple of different ways to
do it and sometimes it really is going
to depend on your situation but one of
the things that I like to share is that
as as quickly and as well as Udacity is
growing it's not a household name it's
not the same idea of going to you know
blank University or or whatever and so
as it continues to grow it will start
becoming more known but you in my
opinion it wouldn't be helpful to just
simply list out digital marketing
nanodegree Udacity October 20 19 because
if people aren't fully familiar with
what you dasa T is or what a nano degree
is that could mean two hours it could
mean two days two weeks but as we don't
know a nano degree program does not ever
get completed that quickly and so it may
be helpful for you to provide some
context in to how long the program takes
maybe including a link to the curriculum
maybe showcasing some of your projects
which can be really helpful but I would
definitely encourage you to do more than
simply listing it just because not
everybody
gonna know exactly what that means
obviously some of the bigger companies
some of the tech companies are gonna be
a lot more familiar but if you're
applying for jobs I would highly
recommend that you provide a little bit
more context for people who may not be
fully familiar with what that looks like
but I think that's a question that might
be a little bit more helpful if you were
to schedule a coaching session so we can
think about what makes the most sense
for you specifically versus kind of
generally for Udacity students cool any
other questions feel free to unmute
yourself if you'd rather chat or type it
in the in the chat box as well but are
there any other questions before we wrap
up breakfast do you have a question no
really okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go ahead
and mute you I think it might be a
little too distracting okay sometimes so
much about Udacity in one page resume so
I think that that it goes back to the
other question I think that's a very
individualized kind of question it might
be a little bit better help if you
schedule a coaching call with myself or
one of the other coaches so that we can
look at your current situation and see
what things can be moved what things can
be taken out what things can be swapped
and switched that's a very kind of
individualized question that can
sometimes be hard to address and don't
feel bad if you have to go over one page
I know that there's a lot of different
opinions like I said with a lot of
different things as it relates to job
searching people will say that it has to
be this way and I think that that
continues to be proven wrong as people
continue to do things that aren't in
alignment with that and still get jobs
and still impress employers and so if
you need to go to two pages I think
that's perfectly fine I think once you
start approaching like three pages it's
kind of like is everything on here
really relevant is every
you're really showcasing your ability to
do well in this specific job or are you
just kind of listing out everything that
you've ever done so I would encourage
you to schedule a coaching session yes
the recording will be available it'll be
on YouTube as soon as it's processed and
uploaded it's also helpful to check out
that Udacity YouTube page to see all of
the other webinars that we've hosted in
the past where should I put Udacity in
education section or work project
section on a resume once again that's a
question that I think would be better
addressed in a coaching call because it
can depend sometimes some people I've
seen it in their education section look
great some people have had a separate
section for projects which looks great
it just depends on your current
situation and what makes the most sense
because your resume also has to have
somewhat of a logical flow to it you
don't want to be bouncing around
everywhere trying to figure out what's
going on so I think that just depends
are you still working for you to acity
absolutely that's why I'm doing this
webinar so if you do want to schedule a
coaching call feel free to and I'll
probably be working on that next webinar
as well around the topic of personal
branding since it sounds like people
might be interested in that okay well
thank you all so much for attending we
had quite a bit of people join so thank
you for taking time out of your day to
invest in yourself and really learn how
you can start developing experience and
gaining these experiences for yourself
it's a it's a great skill to kind of
learn and something that you should
probably continue doing throughout your
entire career so if you do have any
additional questions or want some
individual ideas definitely feel free to
check out some of our previous webinars
make sure to check out some of our
future webinars stay engaged in the
student hub schedule coaching sessions
we are here to help you but one of the
things that I always mentioned as
students is we're not going to do it for
you so we can't get experienced for you
we can't contact employers for you we
can give you the skills that you need in
order to gain those experiences for
yourself but there you have to kind of
meet us halfway and you have to be
willing to put in that work for yourself
as well so once again thank you for
joining
feel free to schedule coaching
session with myself or one of the any
other coaches if you do have additional
questions feel free to contact career
tech support at udacity.com or post your
questions in the student hub we should
be able to either answer or direct you
to the appropriate channels once again
thank you all I'll make sure to get this
recording up as soon as I can so that
you all can watch it as many different
times as you want but thank you all I
hope you have a great rest of your day